an armed group calling itself m23 has
been advancing to gomer in eastern
democratic republic of congo
its rebels have been fighting the
congolese army for about two months
u.n experts say they have evidence
rwanda is barking the rebels the rwandan
government has denied this
hundreds of people in some areas have
fled from their homes in recent
after
days
captured our village we are afraid of
them when they are fighting they do not
differentiate between soldiers and
civilians we do not want to die here
this latest conflict is just one of many
in the east of the country i say
pre-occupied so when the u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken visited
kinshasa
security martyrs dominated the talks we
are
very concerned by credible reports that
rwanda has provided support to m23
we call on all parties in the region to
stop any support or cooperation with m23
he's also due to hold talks with london
president paul kagame
democratic republic of congo and rwanda
have heard years of tensions with both
sides accusing each other for finding
rebellions
in reality the u.s was the first country
to be concerned about rwanda's support
for m23
angola has been trying to broker peace
between the two countries but a recent
peace deal did not calm things blinken
will complete his three-nation tour on
thursday he also visited south africa
analysts say the u.s wants to increase
diplomacy to counter russia's growing
influence on the african continent
catherine soy al jazeera